any minute joe gans you know guys like
that and other guys who wasn't really
famous to about certain achievement the
one guy named Willie Richie Polish
fighter became lightweight champion in
1908 9012 no nineteen year 1910 1912 run
that period fourteen and when he was
younger his first fight he got knocked
out but he saved the cart so he got
little experience ten fights lady fights
a guy the guy was a little bigger than
he's 133 pounds of guy hundred thirty
nine forty pounds so it's a close fight
it's a draw
but Willie Ricci the guy really beat him
but the guy called it a draw the other
guy won so the guy's manager smacks him
on the back all right
you gotta fight again in two weeks back
then they for real quick and they said
he came to the to the weigh-in but until
the fight Willie Ricci was so scared of
the guy he couldn't tie his shoes
he can't move him he just so effectively
the feet up gotta fight this guy again
and he really kicked my ass last night I
gotta fight him again and he gets
couldn't do but discipline he had
discipline and even they move slow he
was slowly tied to shoes he walked to
the gym you know he hated the word
discipline made him get to the gym and
I'm two weeks over he trained he got the
crap kicked out of my trainer he's just
miserable
he knows this guy's not til next time so
he left a way in his way then he makes
the weight he scared the dust for the
whole two weeks the scariest moment of
his life so the guys manager comes back
money back we took it easy with you last
time glass knocked out quick this time
and so once you do that the guy hit him
on the back to the little guy and he
said um he says nothing
he goes and he waits for the guy he's
dying hunter hour goes by two hours go
by the guy doesn't show up they postpone
the fight Willie Ricci gets to money and
he goes to the guys manager see you
would mean to me and if you were nice to
me I might have gave you some of this
money cuz your guy didn't show up but
what I learned from it
what bully um Willie Ritchie learn from
me whether that the guy was just as
scared as I was but more and that's what
I learned about myself I know
in the scanners I was fighting I realize
this has more afraid than I was of the
me that I wasn't done and that's why my
whole game started changing as far as my
approach towards fighting you know and I
know how they feel that no has most
fight itself and no more fighters don't
gotta come a total amount of control
over their emotions and the ones that do
maybe you think it's bring it out and
get them lose the control you pressured
them a little bit irritate them a little
bit and is force them to so many
different perspectives